A new trailer for Armored Core 6 has just
rolled onto the scene, and I have so much
new gameplay to break down for you here.
But this video will also get you up to
speed with how old Armored Core games
used to play..because I want everyone to
understand just how far this series has come.
So if you've never played an Armored Core game
before, then this is the video for you. And even
if you're familiar with the series - there are
huge secrets in this trailer that you would have
missed unless you watched it frame-by-frame.
So..let's break it down -
But not before we catch up on the story.
The trailer starts with our approach to Rubicon,
a devastated planet that was razed to ash with the
outbreak of a new substance called "Coral".
We're close to Rubicon. Wake the dog up.
I think he's talking about us. We do play
as an mercenary for hire, after all.
Handler "Walter" verified. Activating
cerebral Coral control device.
It seems we even have a handler, called "Walter".
And we're essentially being used as their attack
dog.
And Coral, that new, dangerous, pink-red
substance discovered on Rubicon...is playing a
part in a "cerebral control" of our character..
Who is an augmented human,
piloting an Armored Core.
Augmented human C4-621 has awakened.
It's nothing new in the Armored Core
series...for an AC pilot to be augmented in some
way. Throughout the series has been something
called the "Human PLUS" program, which was an
experimental procedure that cybernetically meshed
the human with their Armored Core to improve
performance. And then in Armored Core 4, there
were Lynx pilots, whose nerves were literally
"linked" with their mech's electronics.
So I assume something similar is the
case in Armored Core 6. We are almost
certainly an "Augmented human" because
it gives us greater control of our mech.
But speaking of control..let's talk gameplay. To
date, I've played these seven Armored Core games,
so I'll be showing my clips from these
games in order to get everyone up to
speed on the same page regarding how
Armored Core has traditionally played,
and how Armored Core 6 appears
to be similar, or different.
...and the first thing I want
to talk about, is boosting.
Boosting in Armored core is when you
press a button to activate your thrusters,
which significantly increases your
movement speed. In older AC games,
you can either boost along the ground and
try avoid enemy fire that way, or tap the
boost button again to enter a boosted flying mode.
And this ability - to fight in three-dimensions,
all while handling multiple weapons at the same
time and managing a lot of systems all at once
is at the very..core of Armored Core's combat.
Now, in previous games, being airborne like this
is demanding. It drains your Energy bar, seen on
the left here. Think of energy as the equivalent
of the stamina bar in Dark Souls. Energy is
drained by certain actions, like moving with
your boosters, or when firing certain weaponry,
or by activating unique abilities - and it's
recovered passively whenever you're not boosting
- especially if you're completely standing still.
Completely drain your energy bar, and your regen
rate will be severely punished, allowing enemies
to make quick work of you. Thus, it's extremely
important to watch your energy in these games,
and unless your AC is specifically built light,
and with a powerful energy generator and boosters,
it's actually difficult to achieve
sustained flight in most of the games.
In the first three series of AC games, efficient
movement was achieved by something called "bunny
hopping", which requires you to activate and
deactivate your boosters like this, allowing
you to ascend and be avoidant, and then recover
your energy as you freefall, only to start the
process again and maintain your momentum when you
hit the ground, as long as you time it properly.
But then in Armored Core 4, the series
was revamped in a really big way,
and mechs overall became faster, more energy
efficient..and more airborne. They were even
given a dedicated button for "side boosting",
which allows you to trade a chunk of energy for
an instantaneous speed boost in any direction.
This change was pretty huge for the series,
and while I kind of missed the whole bunny
hopping thing, side boosting also required
skill and timing, and allowed the game
to be played at a faster pace. And when I
say faster..I really mean it. Armored Core 4
requires crazy reflexes at times. Especially
when you're fighting another mech that uses all
the same side-boosting techniques as you do.
And then there was Armored Core 5, which was way
more grounded, and way weightier, in general.
Anyway, the reason I'm talking about boosting
first, is because the big question to many
fans was "how fast" Armored Core 6 would play.
Will it have this methodical momentum like the
first generation of games? Or will combat
be frantic and dizzying like in Armored
Core 4? Or will things be more grounded
and weighty like in Armored Core 5?
And now that we've finally seen gameplay, I think
the pacing kind of looks like it has it all. I can
actually comprehend what's happening on-screen, so
it's not as fast as Armored Core 4 - but it DOES
retain the side boosts of AC4, which is fantastic.
There's some evidence in this clip that sustained
flying is possible..so maybe it's not completely
like Armored Core 5's grounded combat....but
then this heavy tank build does looks like it
plays more like Armored Core 5, so maybe a bit
of that groundedness depends on your build.
Thankfully producer Yamamura Ogura clarifies,
stating: “The average movement speed across
the game is somewhere between Armored Core 3
and Armored Core 5,” he replies. But "With
instantaneous bursts of speed and sudden
changes of tempo, combat can often reach the
dizzying heights of say, Armored Core 4.”
And according to Yamamura, this is
achieved "thanks to a button activated
movement skill called the Assault boost".
“Assault Boost is an offensive action that
helps close the gap between enemies and lets
you quickly go from long distance to close
range,” Yamamura tells us. It will also provide
some incredible chain abilities when fighting".
be achieved by boosting from a standstill
position, and that's something we see as
well at a few points in the trailer, where the
legs play a part in the initial lift-off.
Speaking of jumping specifically though, there's a part in the trailer where the character actually
does an enormous vertical leap. But if you
look closely, they're actually doing this
on a jump pad..which is not unlike the
spirit springs that Torrent can use in
Elden Ring. The four vertical yellow lights here
probably extend high into the air so that it's
clear where these jump pads are located.
The fact that these are necessary at all
suggests to me that either aerial abilities are
significantly reduced for all mechs across the
board compared to previous games, or at least
that aerial abilities are significantly reduced
for SOME heavier builds. These might just be a way
for all mechs to achieve verticality int he level,
and progress regardless of their design.
Which brings us to customisation.
Armored Core's gameplay doesn't start in its
missions. It starts in the garage. Experimenting
with mech designs and fine-tuning your mech is
a TON of fun once you start to understand the
intricacies of all the parts and how they work.
But..I didn't understand that when I first started
playing Armored Core. At first going into the
garage to shop for parts was this intimidating
chore, because the options and stats were utterly
overwhelming. I just wanted to put together a mech
and get back into the missions. But - it's funny
- now I've played seven Armored Core games, and I
now understand a ton of the intricacies of
building..and now it's the other way around.
I don't build mechs so that I can do missions..I
do missions so that I can afford new parts,
and get back into the garage. Fine tuning
my mech to my tastes is a huge part of the
joy for me now. I get it. This is what Armored
Core is about. It's about taking any mission,
and doing anything for that shiny new part you
have your eyes on. And I when I say anything..I
mean..you really do some awful things so that
you can afford parts, in this game. It's great.
Two of the most important customisable
parts in Armored Core are your generator,
and your boosters. Put simply, generators
determine how much max energy you have,
and how fast you regenerate energy..and
boosters determine the power of your thrust,
the direction your thrust favours, and
and how efficient that thrust is. However,
the dreaded attribute you always
need to be aware of..is weight.
Because every part in Armored Core has a weight
to it, and it's because of this that I would argue
that the next most important part of your mech is
its legs, because it's those legs that determine
how much weight your AC can carry. Go over your
legs' weight limit, and you'll have a bad time.
In previous games, legs generally determine
whether you're a lightweight, middleweight or
heavy build. But on top of that, legs can give
different properties to your mech. Just listen
to this quote from game producer Yasunori Ogura:
"With AC6, one area we focused on was to make sure
that the customization aspect is not just about
parameters going up and down and numerical values
changing, but how these changes are reflected
in the feel of the action. As much as possible,
in particular, (this is reflected by) the
leg parts which control the AC's movement."
And in the new trailer, we DO see a variety
of mechs where it's clear that their legs are
a huge part of the way they play. Take the tank
with tread legs, for example. In previous games,
I never found a use for tread legs. This is what
it looks like using tread legs in Armored Core 3,
for example. But THIS is what
it looks like using tread legs in Armored Core
6! These legs change the traversal method of the
mech, allowing them to drift, AND they seemingly
give the player a charge attack that allows
them to blast through a barricade of enemies.
Another familiar leg type to me were these quad
legs, which traditionally allow the player to
fire back weapons while moving, as seen here. With
most other leg types, these back weapons required
you to stand still. But in AC6's trailer..these
quad legs can also do this: they can jump you
high into the air and transform into additional
boosters, which..seems to help this AC hang in
the air and deliver death from above. In Armored
Core 3 there was a booster extension that helped
you hang in the air..I wonder if that's what
these legs are doing. If sustained vertical
flight actually isn't a big part of AC6,
then these could be very unique indeed.
Most clips in the trailer show the
player with standard bipedal legs,
but even then these do seem to have additional
boosters attached, which might be cool..
But these bipedal legs have to be my favourites
from the trailer. They're not just bipedal legs,
they're reverse-jointed bipedal legs, which is a
type that has traditionally helped with jumping
and aerial movement in previous games.
So, fittingly.. and this AC6 mech DOES do
an insanely fast dodge jump here. Not
only that, but the legs also give them
a unique attack. A dismantling kick, that
absolutely obliterates this wheel droid.
This character is extremely lightweight and
agile, and is able to move behind a droideka
with blistering speed, using an energy shotgun
to blast them before they even know what hit
them. Now, I've had fast AC's in previous
games..but this is on another level..and
it's because its turning speed.
Turning speed in Armored Core
games is traditionally very slow.
Yes, you can choose parts that increase
turning speed, and yes, in armored core 4 you
can even perform a boost-turn..but it's still
slow. The boost turn isn't even explained in
Armored Core 4..but I'm excited to show that
the boost turn CLEARLY plays a big part again in Armored Core 6, and it's on a whole other level, because
Blink,
and you'll miss it. Literally. It took just
9 FRAMES for these mechs to boost-turn
for a complete 180. 9 FRAMES! And here,
in just 11 more frames, the camera completely
catches up, and it's now that I assume the player
is fully locked on to their target and able to
attack. That. Is. Insane. For Armored Core.
Now..the Heads-up-display is disabled in this
trailer..so I can't say for sure: but the way
the camera moves makes me think that the player is
actually locked on to this enemy in this clip. And
I mean that in the Souls sense, where you press
R3 to lock on to an enemy, and the camera stays
centred on them. And..if I'm right..that's
potentially huge for the series as well.
Because traditionally, lock-on in Armored Core
doesn't work like it does in Souls games. Instead,
there's like a big box in the middle of your
screen that you control as you turn your mech
with the right analogue stick, and anything
within that box starts being locked on-to.
The size and shape and speed and range of this
lock on is governed by a part of your Armored
Core called the FCS, and different FCS parts have
different sizes and shapes for the lockon box,
as well as the different speeds and
ranges that this box targets with.
Now, Armored Core 4 DID have a manual lockon
button that helped you stay on certain enemies,
but it was still pretty loose and would
fall off if you weren't facing them
properly. Which..happens a lot because
of the standard slow turning speed.
So the fact that this AC6 mech and its camera is
able to turn THIS fast, and potentially retain
lockon the whole time has huge implications
for the gameplay. It also seems to be happening
as well in this scene, as your AC floats
around the enemy here, if you look closely.
So while From Software might be making it easier
to turn and control your mech..but that doesn't
mean the game is going to be easier. No. Knowing
From Software, it just means the game will have
design space to be difficult in different areas.
For example, from what I've played of Armored
Core, single player missions have very rarely
ever required you to read enemy movements,
and avoiding their telegraphed attacks. These
older games are NOT like Souls games are, in that
regard. At most, you'll be able to outmanoeuvre
slow missiles at a distance..especially in
Armored Core 4 with its side-boosting..but
even then you're usually so busy flying
around, watching your energy, your ammo,
staying at the optimal range for your weapons, and
firing two weapons at once..that you just don't
always have time to dodge things..and watching for
telegraphed is really not that much of a thing.
But that is clearly not the case
in Armored Core 6. These enemies,
and bosses, are using very telegraphed attacks.
For example, this enemy AC has a chain-whip melee
weapon with a vertical slam, that
I bet you can side-boost to avoid.
THIS enemy AC has a unique back unit that
overboosts them forcefully forward into a, linear
lanced grab attack that our character narrowly
avoids, only to be caught by it moments later.
This spider-like mech has a slow
laser, followed by a pincir slam
that the character boosts away from. Not to
mention a female voice warns us to "watch out"
and warns us about a "coral response from the
generator", which might be mid-battle warnings
not unlike Sekiro's own attack warning system.
And this boss might be the best example, with two
giant club arms that can rotate horizontally in
one animation..and slam vertically, in another.
I don't think I'm wrong when I say..these attacks
wouldn't look out of place in a Souls game. And
from my experience with Armored Core, these sorts
of attacks are NOT common. This is new. We know
from past interviews that From Software actually
spends a ton of time designing enemy attacks to
be properly telegraphed to the player, so
that the player can recognise patterns,
and react appropriately. I'd actually argue
that this is a huge design component of what
makes a game "soulslike". Soulslike combat is
all about the dodge roll, and the dodge roll
only works if enemy attacks are telegraphed.
And on that note, I want to call out that quite a
lot of people criticised me for my last video on
Armored Core 6. In that video I speculated, based
on solid evidence at the time, that Armored Core 6
would have soulslike elements. I argued that From
Software have learned things from the Souls series
that they will almost certainly apply to their
storytelling and combat design..and I stand by
that statement. In fact, I think I'm already being
proven right with these telegraphed boss
attacks, and with the new lock-on method.
Many commenters misrepresented me as if
I said this would be Dark Souls but with
mechs..but I never said that. Again,
I still think this will be an Armored
Core game at its heart..but I'm confident
think there will also be some new elements
that Souls fans will be quite familiar with.
"AC6 is an attempt to take both the knowledge
and experience gained from the development
of our previous titles and combine it with
the fun of Mech customization that the AC series
has always embraced, and in this sense, we hope
to create a new Mech action game that is worthy
of modern FromSoftware standards. Specifically,
we're developing this game with an awareness of
the things that FromSoftware has always embraced
in its other action games: such as an intricate
map structure, combat design that allows players
to deal with enemies by carefully observing their
movements, and the ability to overcome challenging
situations with ingenuity and creativity".
But moving on. When asked about their goals in
combat design, he says that the individuality
of melee weapons is a key point. So let's
talk about weapons in Armored Core.
In these games, typically you have four
main weapon slots. Left hand, right hand, left
back, and right back. Two of these are usually
active at the same time, allowing you to dual-fire
a HUGE variety of weapon types. Sometimes you'll
want to dual wield machine guns, others you might
want to dual fire both missile slots on the back,
or maybe you want one of each weapon type..or
maybe you're this guy and you want your back
slot to be taken up by an entire missile cage. Or
maybe you're this dude, and you want to replace
your back slots with an overboost unit. There's
SO much variety..even in this trailer alone:
but another common loadout is to have a melee
weapon equipped in your left hand..and in
particular, that strategy seems to be the one
making a BIG return here in Armored Core 6.
Because In the trailer we can see a diverse array
of melee weapons with different characteristics.
There's one familiar laser blade, yes, but then
there's also a chain whip that has long range,
a twinblade that does multiple strikes, an energy
lance grab attack, a horizontal spinning cleave,
a flamethrower on this enemy AC..not to mention
the pile bunker and cluster bomb launcher seen in
the cinematic trailer. That's a ton of diversity.
In previous games, melee weapons were typically
just simple blades that all shared the
same attack animations. And while they are
extremely damaging..they were typically also quite
difficult to hit with. If something is flying, or
moving more than 5 kilometres per hour, you were
going to have a bad time. It gets better in games
like Armored Core For Answer where your character
really hones in on their targets, but until then
melee weapons are usually something you just use
as a backup weapon for when you're out of ammo, or
as a utility weapon to take out tanky opponents.
Usually, I preferred to dual wield ranged weapons
instead, whenever that was possible, that was the
optimal way to deal damage in most missions. And
while dual wielding ranged weapons is clearly
possible again in Armored Core 6 based on some
of the loadouts we can see..I'm feeling tempted
to incorporate melee weapons when I finally play
this game..especially if lock-on really is a lot
more reliable like it is in the Souls games.
Melee is a big part of the newly combo-based
combat. When answering a question on what's new
in Armored Core 6, producer Yamunori
Ogura states that "In the trailer,
you may have also seen a part where the core is
deployed by an AC to generate a shock wave, and
the pile bunker is then used against an opponent
who is reeling back from the shockwave. This kind
of building combos with multiple weapons aspect is
an appeal of AC6's unique assembly and combat".
In another response, Yamunori encourages
players to make use of something called
the "stagger system", in order to break the
posture of enemies so that you can get close
for a melee strike. I...think that's awesome. A
stagger system sounds like exactly what Armored
Core needs to add an ebb and flow to the
combat. In early games, fights sometimes
just feel like bunny hopping in a circle around
an opponent and pelting them with ammunition until
they die. Having a posture bar AND a health bar
should help fights become more dynamic, and give
you a few ways to break down your opponents.
Remember: this game is now being directed by the
legendary Masaru Yamamura, who I respect a lot,
because they were lead game designer of Sekiro,
and I think responsible for Sekiro's combat
system, as well. And Sekiro had a fantastic
stagger system..one that probably inspired Elden
Ring's own stagger system..and now, it seems,
Armored Core's as well. Yamamura states:
"Another addition to the series’ combat is
a “stagger” element: if an AC takes too many hits
over a short period of time, its Attitude Control
System will be overloaded, making it vulnerable
for a short time. Both continuous hits and big,
powerful strikes will cause stagger damage,
encouraging you to keep up the pressure on
the opponent. The damage inflicted to an
enemy’s stagger gauge varies from weapon
to weapon. It can also be affected by factors
like distance, adding additional strategy in
equipping and using these armaments in combat."
Another part that I'm extremely curious about
are shields, which are utilised by mechs in
the trailer here..here..here, and here.
Now, shields have been in Armored Core games
before as a type of extension part, and while I
only tried them once, I didn't feel like they were
super impactful. So you could either choose from
solid shields that were heavy, or energy shields
that drained your energy bar when used..and in
this trailer, all the shields we see are energy
shields, attached in a back weapon slot. They come
out here in..literally within one frame, which is
insanely fast - and it seems like the player holds
them up manually like they do in Souls games,
though it's hard to be sure at this stage.
Speaking of extension parts, one in the trailer
might be responsible for giving you scan pulse
ability. Or perhaps it's like Armored Core 5,
where a dedicated button entered you into a
passive scan mode, alllowing you to mark enemies
hiding behind walls. Locking on to enemies while
they're behind walls has actually always been
a feature of Armored Core games, and it's great
for missiles, because you can load your
missile lock, peek out from cover, shoot
missiles, then retreat safely and build up your
locks again. In fact, in this AC6 trailer we see
these shoulder missiles react to the lock on, as
the missiles prep as the sensor picks up enemies,
which is a great little detail.
But it's hard to know at this stage
where all these utility items like scanners and
shields are attached. In past games, utility
items could exist on your back, as extensions,
inside your AC..and sometimes even your armor
parts themselves have utility functions built
into them. For example, head armor often have
inbuilt radar functions, torso parts have had
deployable drones and overboost functions,
and there are even weapon arms that straight-up
replace your standard arms with cannons.
Finally, in the cinematic trailer, we see an
EMP attached to what seems like the core of
the unit..so that might even be an option.
We see this explosion in actual gameplay
as well - it reminds me of Assault Armor in
Armored Core 4 - a last-resort attack that
consumes your primal armor, weaponising it
and dealing massive damage to the opponent
at your own expense. The interview suggests that
this is a sort of EMP, and might just be a great
AOE option against multiple opponents. What's
funny here is that you can see an enemy mech
attempting this same animation..buut they did it
a little too late, and we get ours off first.
Callsign "Raven".
Priority subject
for termination, high on the list.
Why hide behind another's callsign?
Despite being called Augmented Human C4-621
earlier in the trailer, there's clearly a bit
of intrigue behind our character because we're
also addressed with another name in that same
trailer. A callsign. Raven. This..is an extremely
nostalgic word for longtime fans of the series,
as in most of the early games, the pilots of
Armored Core's were referred to as Ravens, and
the home hub of all Raven operations was usually
called some variation of a "Raven's Nest" - which
doubled as an organisation that mediates the
Ravens' contracts with various employers. But
regardless of whether our Raven is a reference
here, or something more - Armored Core 6 does
take place in a new setting, and From Software
are clear that you don't need knowledge of
prior stories to understand what's going on here.
This is because AC6 takes place in a future where
interstellar travel is commonplace, so events from
past games are VERY removed from this distant star
system called Rubicon 3. But no matter how far
they are, it seems this universe can't escape
the greed of megacorporations. These companies
"can't resist the siren song of the Coral",
and "continue to wage for it", despite its
destructive properties having reduced this
planet to ash, contaminating its climate and
turning it towards extreme cold. Therefore,
the world we're exploring is multilayered -
with shiny mining constructs and energy farms
now built on top of the hollowed-out industrial
ruins of the old world, which is defended by
the indigenous forces of the planet, even now.
Reminds me a bit of my Displate I helped design
called "future souls". Link in the description.
But man..I'm so excited for this game now. It's
been really fun learning to love the old games,
knowing a new one is coming. Because you'd sense
just how much this series will benefit from the
touch of modern From Software. Even Miyazaki
himself has said that past-him is jealous of the
sheer budget and resources that From Software can
now bring to bear on their projects. It's clear
that older Armored Core games wanted to have
the player exploring vast subterranean structures
and marveling at the scale of the world..because
they ATTEMPT to be designed this way - but in
reality, you often explore the same tunnels,
and the same open worlds, with the same repeated
assets. Compare that with the incredible setpieces
and assets that we're seeing in this trailer..and
I'm excited for them to be fully able to achieve
what they clearly set out to achieve
with Armored Core, so many years ago.
Also, some of the coolest moments for
me, in the early Armored Core games,
were when you earned new parts for your AC during
a mission, rather than just buying parts in the
shop. This could be done by finding them in
the level, by defeating enemy ACs, or sometimes
even by just completing missions, or S-ranking
them. With these clearly more detailed levels,
and with the familiar branching mission structure
of the games confirmed to be making a return,
I hope discoverable parts make a return as well.
Because it really is exciting to experiment with
new parts..and there's no where I preferred to
put weapons to the test, than in the Arena.
The Arena has taken a few different forms
throughout the games, but essentially it's a
way to pit your AC against others that exist in
the world, and fight for a higher ranking. The
intense dogfights you can have with armored core
is my favourite part of these games outside of the
garage, so I was very happy to learn from a recent
interview that this will be returning in Armored
Core 6, in an arena designed as a simulator
where you can train against other ACs you may
encounter out in your missions. Not to mention,
PvP arenas are confirmed for Armored Core 6 as
well, and I guarantee that's something I'll get
heavily addicted to, when the game comes out.
I also think their storytelling has come SO far
since they started making these games. I'll be
honest, the old games do NOT grab me with their
storytelling. The mission briefings and cutscenes
usually put me to sleep. The best moments for me
though are when characters are bantering in the
middle of deathly combat, or when the female
voiceover gives you mid-mission information,
or a debriefing at the end. I also
love being allied with other ACs and
hearing their struggles or boasting
during combat. A few games even had
consort systems where you could recruit
allied ACs as long as you paid them some
of your mission profits, so I'm excited for
a system like that to potentially return
in some capacity here as well.
But..I've talked long enough. Let's
end on the final note of the trailer, which I
speculate mightc be reminding us that we're a
lone mercenary. A slave, to the highest
bidder, used to achieve their goals.
Let's see how far they can fly on borrowed wings
Subscribe for more Armored Core
content..and I'll see you next time.